le traditionnel débat de l'entre-deux
tours se tiendra mercredi prochain un
débat qui opposera Emmanuel Macron à
Marine Le Pen pour la seconde fois
bonsoir Marine Le Pen bonsoir Emmanuel
Macron bonsoir bienvenue pour ce débat
de l'antre de Tours et modalités sont
désormais connues deux heures de débat
animé par deux journalistes Gilles
Bouleau présentateur du 20h de TF1
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous il est à
salami qui a notamment animé Elysée 2022
durant toute cette campagne merci d'être
là vous allez avoir un peu plus de deux
heures pour convaincre les Français
Lapix qui a été écarté de ce débat à la
demande des deux finalistes qu'il a
juste au pugnace j'ai l'impression que
c'est moi qui ai provoqué
la question est posée est-ce que la
liberté de la presse et entachée par ce
choix commun d'ailleurs des des deux
candidats
on fait des grandes émissions
et ça c'est toujours fait comme
président et qu'une chaîne choisie sur
l'interviewer
interviewé
il y a pas que deux femmes dans une
station
moi je regrette on n'arrête pas de dire
qu'il y a une collusion entre les
journalistes et le personnel politique
qui mange ensemble qui se connaissent
qui sont copains et puis après quand il
y en a une qui gratte un peu on dit bah
non on la veut pas sur les faudrait
savoir donc moi je trouve que
ça pourrait pas se passer dans les pays
anglo-saxons parce que il y a une sorte
de 4e pouvoir qui est vraiment
sacralisée et en plus là dans cet
exercice de l'entre-deux-tours
franchement ils vont elle va pas poser
de questions elle est là juste pour dire
maintenant ça va être l'immigration
maintenant on va parler de l'économie
maintenant on va parler de ceci c'est
juste une nana qui va donner l'horloge
et qui va donner le temps de parole il y
a pas d'inquisition voilà il y a pas de
et donc vraiment je trouve que ça c'est
c'est lancer un mauvais signal de dire
que on va choisir moi j'aurais préféré
que TF1 parce que TF1 et France 2 que
TF1 disent on a décidé de et c'est comme
ça et pas autrement et France de dise on
a décidé d'eux et c'est comme ça et pas
autrement voilà parce que c'est c'est
aussi une façon de montrer que il y a
une il y a une indépendance après du
coup ce sera aller pour France 2 et
rigolo
c'est pas la plus cool les journalistes
vous dites c'est pas la plus cool c'est
pas là le problème le problème c'est que
pour moi Anne-Sophie Lapix elle est
idéologue c'est à dire que elle est
notamment très fortement anti-Marine Le
Pen je suis désolé il y a des années
c'était presque un pugilat verbal on
sent que ces questions sont orientées à
l'aune de ces convictions moi c'est ça
qui me gêne pour Emmanuel Macron aussi
n'en voulait pas mais c'est moi mais
deux n'en voulez pas je suis d'accord
avec toi si elle se présenter comme une
éditorialiste or elle se présente comme
une journaliste agressive avec Marine Le
Pen très agressive
qui posent des questions
mais c'est pas pareil équilibré on sait
très bien que pour le débat d'autres de
Tours il y a pas de question ça peut
être alors c'est pas du tout
pourquoi il passe des heures à choisir
qui va interroger là c'est fou
ne rêvez pas c'est pas une grande
performance pas du tout pas du tout
qui vont balancer comme ça ils vont
essayer de maintenir le temps de parole
vous rigolez Bernard ici le la question
de la tuer une campagne vous rigolez
avec les patrons de chaîne c'est eux qui
décide aussi hein vous avez des infos du
Président
je suis pas au courant je suis pas dans
l'intimité non plus mais non non j'ai
appris ça comme tout le monde dans la
presse cela dit elle arrive à unanimité
pourtant moi je l'ai trouvé assez mais
assez bonne elle rentre dedans mais il
est à Salamé aussi
elle rentre dedans ça respecte pas
l'exercice de l'entre-deux
alors Emmanuel Macron
dans le président elle était très
efficace mais pour une journaliste
pardon mais c'est un fait gloire de
déplaire aux deux candidats qui sont
opposés ça veut dire qu'elle ne
plaignent ni à l'un ni à l'autre et
c'est plutôt positif
pour info Delphine Ernotte la présidente
de France Télévisions soutient
férocement Anne-Sophie Lapix elle
n'était pas d'accord d'être mise sur la
touche mais elle n'a pas eu le choix
mais en tout cas elle a le soutien c'est
très inquiétant si vous dites si
vraiment elle a pas eu le choix
ça a toujours été comme ça
de se poser une question qui n'a pas
lieu d'être ça a toujours été un choix
entre les candidats finalistes et les
rédactions qui se rencontrent des heures
et des heures
la direction il y a les présidents de
chaîne quand même qui se réunissent pour
essayer de trouver un accord avec avec
les deux candidats mais ça a toujours
été comme ça et moi je trouve ça
choquant
moi ça me gêne qui est des pressions
déjà je pense que les gens ne le savent
pas et ça me gêne que les candidats
fassent leur liste de courses en disant
ben je veux lui je veux je veux parler
si je veux pas parler de ça c'est
insupportable cette émission c'est pas
un clip de campagne c'est pas un film
promotionnel c'est un débat qui est
censé aider les gens à faire leur choix
au second tour et informer les gens donc
ils ont pas à choisir qui les interroge
et en plus là encore si elle était que
enfin si elle était que entre guillemets
anti Le Pen et qu'elle dérangeait que
Madame Le Pen ok mais là elle dérange
les deux candidats donc très bien et là
elle est là pour mettre les candidats
façon alors contradiction pas pour leur
servir
dans le débat non non ils font des
relances c'est pas non plus des esprit
crimes ils font quand même des relances
ils ont un très bon c'est une manière de
s'adresser aux candidats de traiter
c'est très important que les médias
choisissent et je ne comprends pas que
les patrons de chaîne ne réagissent pas
on a Delphine le problème c'est pas les
questions piquantes parce que Léa Salamé
en fait Anne-Sophie Lapix aussi la
différence entre les deux c'est que Léa
Salamé elle est respectueuse dans les
questions qu'elle qu'elle donne et dans
les réponses qu'elle reçoit que
Anne-Sophie Lapix et j'étais devant ma
télé
jamais choqué parce que moi j'ai
toujours beaucoup apprécié elle faisait
elle roulait des yeux elle faisait elle
fait elle faisait la gamine j'étais
choquée du coup je suis allée voir sur
Twitter et les gens disaient incroyable
son comportement est tellement
ignoble que limite elle rend Léa Salamé
sympathique alors qu'on sait que les
gens Léa salami parce que un peu dur
avec eux
horrible insupportable regardez en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que donc il
faut la parité d'accord donc à partir du
moment où Anne-Sophie Lapix a été rejeté
TF1 dis-nous on s’arcoutes à Gilles
Bouleau ils n'ont jamais voulu transiser
c'est Gilles Bouleau ou rien du coup ça
exclut par exemple quelqu'un comme
Laurent Delahousse sur France Télé vous
comprenez donc s'insteler a dû entre
guillemets absolument rester sur le
choix d'une femme c'est comme ça
d'ici sur France 2 il y a un homme nous
on prendra Anne-Claire Coudray ils ont
pas non non
elle a été refusée c'est clair coudra
par Marine Le Pen en 2017 alors je ne
sais pas le motif est-ce qu'elle a été
accusée
par par Marine Le Pen en 2017 pourquoi
je ne sais pas en fait c'est un peu
c'est un peu un peu vexant pour les deux
journées qui sont dû c'est qu'en fait on
va la consulter mais c'est le meilleur
compliment voilà avec eux
en plus
leur métier c'est d'être journaliste
d'être neutre on doit pas savoir pour
qui ils ont envie de voter tandis que
quand on fait comme ça
[Musique]
façon
France Inter
à mon avis oui ce débat d'entre deux
tours est super important et Marine Le
Pen
en fait à partir de lundi Marine Le Pen
se met au vert à midi elle va
disparaître des radars elle va partir
dans une maison dans l'Ouest parisien
pour se consacrer uniquement et
seulement à la préparation de ce débat
la même préparé un sparring partner à la
même asparing partner qui va qui est
dans la sociologie un jeune
fonctionnaire qui a la même sociologie
exactement parce qu'elle estime qu'elle
veut pas refaire les erreurs de de 2017
elle veut pas arriver fatiguée elle
avait une migraine ophtalmique etc et
donc elle veut pas arriver surchargée
fatiguée elle va faire que ça de lundi
midi à mercredi juste avant le débat et
donc elle va s'isoler complètement et
avoir ce sparring partner sur tous les
débats est-ce que le président
peux-tu abattre la campagne et la France
je sais pas je crois qu'il est il sera
en campagne là samedi il sera Marseille
je sais et il continue beaucoup les
passages télévisé parce que dimanche il
sera dans 7 à 8 lundi il sera chez
anne-Élisabeth le moi dans cet à vous et
il va être chez Anne-Sophie Lapix dans
la semaine prochaine finalement il va
être dans son vainqueur
justement il a dit je ne la refuse pas
puisque je vais aller dans son vainqueur
d'accord
été retenus donc Gilles Bouleau il est à
Salamé sont quand même de très bons
journalistes bien sûr
de Valérie elle se prépare comme si
c'était Rocky mais elle a peur
d'affronter madame Lapix c'est vraiment
ridicule
le bon sens populaire
ça sera la première ça sera la deuxième
fois depuis la Cinquième République qui
seront pas sur une table ronde mais ils
auront chacun une table c'est à dire les
deux que les deux présentateurs les deux
journalistes Macron et Le Pen il faut
rappeler
la température soit voilà ce soit 21
degrés 5 ou 20,5 voilà de quel côté
il y a quelqu'un qui vérifie évidemment
les plans et parce que les gros plans il
y a chacun il y a un homme ou une femme
de chaque candidat qui va auprès du
réalisateur vérifier les plans qui
seront proposés et comment ils vont
continuer et le profil et pas le
problème
de ce que ça peut dégager ça peut avoir
une incidence sur les gens qui regardent
que chaque plan est important chacun non
aux Etats-Unis par exemple c'est vrai
qu'il est millimètre tout et parfois il
y en a qui refusent d'être filmé en
train d'écouter l'autre absolument donc
tellement vital comme disait Valérie que
la plus que jamais ça va être mesuré au
millimètre est-ce que vous rappelez de
l'audience du précédent débat en 2017
15 millions 60 % il y avait il y avait
8,1 million sur TF1 32 % et 7 millions
27,8 pour France 2 j'ai quand même pour
le même programme et ça va être
passionnant parce que quand même c'est
la France est divisée malheureusement il
y a les pour et les contre ça va être un
débat extrêmement intéressant et moi je
suis tellement désolé que c'est vrai
que il y a un choix à faire
je pense que Marine Le Pen a appris des
erreurs qu'elle a commises lors du
dernier débat de 2017 et du coup le le
débat de cette fois-ci va être encore
plus intéressant à mon avis pierre vous
allez regarder le débat ou vous avez
déjà votre bien sûr
est-ce que ce débat on peut passer pour
qui vous voter ça me regarde pas mais
est-ce que ce débat peut définitivement
vous faire faire un choix pour l'un pour
l'autre honnêtement ah non non parce que
quoi qu'il arrive
voilà quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il
arrive tout sauf le Pen malheureusement
c'est c'est comme ça
[Rires]
alors comme comme il faut que je contre
ma lance
Delphine quoi qu'il arrive non mais non
mais faites pas rentrer dans ce jeu-là
moi je dis juste que chaque Français est
libre d'oser penser et d'oser dire tout
simplement et que si on n'ose pas le
dire on ne fait pas d'élection et puis
voilà et puis on repartir
c'est une réponse de politique
quand on était Miss France on a côtoyé
beaucoup de politique
non mais là moi je trouve que je trouve
qu'on tape trop sur les candidats et
qu'on tape pas assez sur les médias
pardon mais je trouve que c'est très
grave ce qui se passe et on ne voit ça
nulle part à la télé à part en politique
dans quelle émission vous voyez un
invité qui dit en fait je viens si c'est
pas se présentateur là et la chaîne qui
dit oui oui qui se couche qui dit oui
ça serait pas possible mais voilà
impossible en Amérique
dans face à Baba il me semble que
certains candidats qui avaient des
listes de personnes qui ne voulaient
avec qui ne voulaient pas
imaginer rédactions dans les rédaction
même les rédactions de France
Télévisions ou les rédactions de TF1 il
y a aussi des inimitives des jalousies
il y a toujours évidemment déjà là aussi
il y a un problème